اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في ساعه اخباريه جديده
نخصص معظمها للتغطيه المشهد بالسودان لكن
نبدا بابرز العناوين
تجدد الاشتباكات في محيط القياده العامه
بالخرطوم والجيش والدعم السريع يتبادلان
الاتهامات بشان خرق الهدنه
[تصفيق]
الهلال الاحمر السوداني يحذر من تردد
الاوضاع الطبيه ويطالب بمساعدات دوليه
لتجاوز الازمه
على خلفيه الاشتباكات عطله رسميه مفتوحه
للموظفين وطوارئ في ولايتي الجضارف ونهر
النيل
وفي الساعه الاخباريه ايضا
كوريا الشماليه تتعهد بالردع العسكري ردا
على اتفاق سول و واشنطن لتعزيز تعاونها
النووي
[موسيقى]
رغم الهدنه الانسانيه لا تزال مستمره بين
الاطراف في الصراع بالسودان الى ان
اشتباكات تجددت في ولايات سودانيه بينما
تبادل الجيش والدعم السريع الاتهامات
مجددا بشان انتهاك الهدنه المعلنه ياتي
ذلك فيما تتفاقم الاوضاع الطبيه حيث دعا
الهلال الاحمر المنظمات الدوليه الى تقديم
المساعداتها العاجله لتجاوز الازمه
وفي التفاصيل ومع دخول المعارك بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع اسبوعها الثالث وبعد
ليله هادئه شهدتها الخرطوم تجددت اشتباكات
صباح اليوم حيث تشهد منطقتا المهندسين
والصحه اشتباكات بالاسلحه الخفيفه
والثقيله وقصفا بالطيران بحسب مراسل
العربيه وبحسب شهود عام من منطقه الحلفايه
شمال مدينه الخرطوم بحري بدا الجيش في نشر
وحداته والقيام بعمليه تمشيط بعد معارك
عنيفه شهدتها المنطقه امس وتجدد سماع
انفجارات واصوات اطلاق النار في محيط
القياده العامه للجيش
ضخمه جدا
الان
وضخمه جدا
من الجيش
اتهم الجيش السوداني استمرار قوات الدعم
السريع بانتهاك الهدنه المعلنه من خلال
عمليات تحشيد تقوم بها غرب العاصمه
الخرطوم الجيش دان استمرار القصف العشوائي
وعمليات نهب الممتلكات بما فيها البنوك
ومنازل المواطنين وقال بيان للجيش ان قوات
الدعم السريع حولت مستشفى شرق النيل الى
ثقنه عسكريه ومركز قياده لعملياتها البيان
اكد على استمرار الجيش في تهيئه الظروف
المناسبه لنزول الشرطه تدريجيا الى
الشوارع
[موسيقى]
في المقابل اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع الجيش
بمهاجمه مواقع تمركزها في عدد من مناطق
الخرطوم بالمدافع والطائرات بيان الدعم
السريع اشاره الى ان الطائرات الجيش ما
تزال تحلق في سماء الخرطوم وتنتهك الهدنه
الدعم السريع قال ايضا الجيش يستعد لشن
هجوم في العاصمه الخرطوم ومدينه الحلفايه
واندرمان وبحري
هذا واظهرت صور متداوله اشتعال حريق في
بنك السودان المركزي في وقت تعاني فيه
البلاد من حاله انفلات امنه
السودان المركزي
الان الحرب كله من الطالب الاول نحدد
الاخير
الله يسترنا طبعا
الله يسهل
الخرطوم رئيس تحرير صحيفه الجريده اشرف
عبد العزيز اهلا بك استاذ اشرف قبل الحديث
عن اخر التطورات في العاصمه هل لديكم اي
معلومات عن ظروف وملابسات احتراق البنك
المركزي السوداني
والوقت الذي حدث به هذا الحريق
وبالتاكيد يعني ليست هنالك كثير معلومات
عن ذلك باعتبار ان المنطقه تقع في محيط
العمليات الدائره ولكن هنالك تضارب فيما
يتعلق بعمليه الحريق نفسه فالبعض يقول ان
الذي احترقه بنك السودان المركزي فرع
الخرطوم بمعنى هو الذي يقع في محيط
القياده العامه وليس بنك السودان المركزي
الكبير
ولذلك حتى الان لم تتبين المعلومات وهنالك
من يتحدث عن الحريق جزئيا ولم يؤثر بقدر
كبير حتى الان
هو بالفعل حريق جزئي في الجانب الايمن من
المبنى لكن هل تم التعرف عليه ما اذا كان
مبنى البنك المركزي ام احد فروعه
حتى الان معظم الذين يؤكدوني يشيرون الى
انه احد فروعي ولكن
نستقصد في الامر ذات ان المعلومات صعبه
الوصول اليها
طيب الان نشير الى ان نقابه اطباء السودان
تؤكد ارتفاع عدد قتل الاشتباكات من
المدنيين جراءها الى
425 شخصا اذا تاكيدات بارتفاع عدد قتلى
المدنيين جراء اشتباكات الى 425 حسب نقابه
اطباء السودان الان بالعوده الى التطورات
الاحداث ماذا رصدتم من مواجهات منذ صباح
اليوم في العاصمه وباقي الولايات
هذه المواجهات زرت مستمره منذ الامس كانت
هنالك مواجهات وصراع عنيف في المنطقه جنوب
ام درمان هذه المنطقه كانت فيها اشتباك
الكل يدعي انه حقق الانتصارا على الاخر
الجنس يقول ان لديه متحركات قادمه من
الولايات خاصه من ولايه جنوب كردفان وشمال
كردفان وولايه الدين الابيض كانت في
طريقها الى الخرطوم لتطويق هذه المنطقه
والقيام بتنشيطها ولكن اعترضتها من الدعم
السريع وتصدق لها بحسب قوات الدعم السريع
والكل يقول انه اسرع عدد من الجنود
وتمكنها من حسن المعركه وبالتالي الان هذه
المعلومات توصل في اطار محاولات الحرب
النفسيه في المقابل ايضا هنالك ايضا
مواجهات تمت في كفر الحلفايه وما زالت هي
يعني ما قالت
الاشتراكات جاريه اما منطقه محيط القياده
العامه والقصر الجمهوري هي ظلت محل اشتباك
دائم لمواجهه دائما باعتبار انها المنطقه
الاستراتيجيه التي يحاول
كل من الاطراف تسيطر عليها باعتبار انها
يمكن ان تكون مكمله للنصر الماحق الذي
اريد تحقيقه هل هناك من يسيطر على الجسر
الحلفايه الان
ليست هنالك معلومات لكن المعلومات السابقه
منذ الامس كانت جزء قد اغلبكم في الحلفاء
ولو الجيش ايضا متواجد في منطقه كوبري
الحلفايه خاصه المنطقه الغربيه باعتبار ان
هذه المنطقه هي تقترب من او قريبه من
قاعده واد سيدنا العسكريه وهي قاعده جويه
وهنالك كان حديث من بعض انصار بانهم
يريدون الهجوم على هذه القاعده يعني فقط
اشير الى اسم
بيان نقابه اطباء السودان الان يتحدث عن
حصر 94 وفاه جراء الاشتباكات في مدينه
الجنينه غرب دارفور حتى الان وقبل ذلك
اكدت تسجيل
2021 او احدى 90 اصابه بين المدنيين منذ
بدايه الاشتباكات وايضا ارتفاع عدد القتلى
بين المدنيين جراء الاشتباكات الى 425 كل
هذا حسب نقابه اطباء السودان اذا ارقام
الوفي ات والاصابات في ارتفاع في الخرطوم
وباقي الولايات
باعتقادكم هذه الاعداد التي يتم اعلانها
الى اي مدى ربما تحاكي الواقع رغم كل ما
يتم نشره من معلومات عن مفقودين وايضا جثث
في الشوارع هل تم احصاء كل هذه الجثث
والمفقودين ام انها ارقام اوليه
هذه ارقام اوليه باعتبار انها هي توصل
لهذه هي
هؤلاء هم الضحايا الذين يصلون الى
المستشفيات سواء كانوا جثث او سواء كانوا
جرحى في منطقه مثلا غربي دارفور في حضرتها
الجنينه هنالك يستمر لعده ايام وبالتاكيد
هذه الارقام ليست هي الارقام التي تؤكد
عدد الضحايا بالضبط وليس الدقيقه ولكن هي
الارقام التي تحصلها لجنه الاطباء من خلال
الذين كما ذكرتون اليها في المستشفيات
وكان الجثث او سواء كانت جرحى اولاد غربي
دارفور فيها عباده جماعيه حقيقيه عادت
للناس
نجحت جهود احتواء ما يحدث في الجنينه الان
الانباء اشارت الى انه هناك محاولات
لتطويق هذه المواجهات
هنالك اجتهادات محليه كما حدث في ولايه
اخرى ممثله مجاوره لها في ولايه شمال
دارفور مثلا هنالك اجتهاد كان من قبل
الدعماء الاهلين والمجتمع المدني استطاعت
الفصل بين القوات حتى الان وتهدئه الموقف
هنالك محاولات ايضا في الجنينه للوصول
لذات الهدف ولكن حتى الان
بعيدا لان المعرفه في الجنينه هي معركه
تحولت من معركه بين الدعم السريع والجيش
الى معرفه قبليه اهليه لان هنالك ايضا
صراع مكتوم بين القبائل الافريقيه مثلا
قبيله المساليد والقبائل العربيه منذ وقت
طويل وبالتالي من الصعوبه من مكان يعني
ايجاد حلول لهذه المساله الا عن طريق قوات
التفصيل من الجهات المنتزه
تشير الى انه يعني المستشفيات ايضا دخلت
على خط هذه المعارك من خلال استهدافها
الان نقابه الاطباء تقول بانه تعرض مستشفى
البراحه في الخرطوم بحري للقصف يوم امس
وقبل ذلك كان هناك اتهامات للجيش لقوات
الدعم السريع ربما
استخدام مستشفى شرق النيل كمركز لاداره
عملياتهم لماذا يتم استهداف المستشفيات
والمراكز الحكوميه والمؤسسات الوطنيه من
قبل هؤلاء
هذه طبعا هي حرب حماسيه وهذه الحرب
العباسيه بالتاكيد تحصل فيها يحصل يحدث
فيها هذا النوع من الفوضى ومن الصعوبه
والمكان حصر مثل هذه الخسائر في ظل هذه
الظروف خاصه وان الكل يريد ان يحقق
انتصاره فبالتالي يريد ان يستخدم اي مرفق
من المرافق الحكوميه لصالحه ولو على حساب
المواطنين وبالتالي لابد من الضغط في هذا
الجانب خاصه وان الان اكثر من 60 مستشفى
خرجت من العمل ومن الخدمه وهو في الاصل
هذه المستشفيات في ولايه الخرطوم هي لا
تتجاوز 85 مستشفى وبالتالي لابد من ايجاد
حلول حقيقيه لان الامور كل يوم تفارق
الازمه الانسانيه وهذه هي المشكله الحديث
عن ازمه الانسانيه كيف هو الوضع الانساني
في العاصمه الخرطوم هذه الهدن التي تم
تطبيقها ولو بشكل جزئي هل ساهمت في تخفيف
معاناه المواطنين ولا اي مدى هناك امكانيه
للحصول على
المواد الاساسيه وما اذا كانت اسعارها في
المتناول بالنسبه للمواطنين
يعني من الواضح جدا ان هذه الهدنه يعني لم
توقف الحرب فما زال الضحايا يعني في كل
بين الفين والاخرى تجد هنالك قتله وجرحى
وهذا واضحا حتى من خلال تقرير لجنه
الاطباء الذي لم يرصد كلها هؤلاء الضحايا
النقطه الثانيه ايضا يعني هنالك اشكالات
متعلقه بانه اثناء هذه الفتنه ينشط كثير
من الذين يقومون بالسرقه والناس والسلب
وهم ايضا مسلحون ويتعرض للمواطنين اثناء
سرقتهم الى نوع من انواع التعدي عليهم
بشكل مستمر النقطه الثالثه ايضا البنوك هي
الان مغلقه وبالتالي هنالك اشكالات
المتعلق بالدفع الالكتروني واستحمل
الالكتروني وبالتالي هنالك البنوك وكل
المؤسسات هناك هناك عطله الى اجل غير مسمى
وبالتالي تداعيات هذا الامر على الناس هل
سيتم دفع الرواتب كيف سيعيشون من يعتمدون
على عملهم بالمياومه
انعكاسات هذا الامر
على سكان ولايه الخرطوم وايضا باقي
الولايات التي تم فيها فرض حاله الطوارئ
بالتدريجيا اصبحت الامور وترى للاسوء يعني
يبدو انه
الاوضاع كانت يعني هي سيئه ولكنها تسير
الى الاسوا لان من الواضح جدا ان الحكومه
غير قادره على هذه المرتبات حتى الان وحتى
البنوكيه مغلقه وحتى مساله الدفع
الالكترونيه تكاد تكون شبكه الانترنت في
كثير من تعيق التعامل بها اذا هنالك مشكله
حقيقيه هنالك
المعروضه في الاسواق لكنها لا تجد من
يشتريها لمثل هذه الظروف الناس يعيشون في
اوضاع صعبه الاوضاع اذا استمرت بهذه
الحاله ستنزل بمجاعه خاصه وان السودان
معروف بحسب المتحده اكثر منهم يتعرضون الى
نقص في المواد الغذائيه وهم في حاله اشبه
بالمجاعه الفجوه الغذائيه كانت كبيره حتى
قبل الحرب
فماذا ستقوم بعد الحرب بالتاكيد ستكون
اكبر وهذه هي الفاجعه الحقيقيه التي
تستدعي التحرك السريع فيما يتعلق بمعالجه
هذه الازمه
نشير فقط معك الى انه نقابه اطباء السودان
اكدت ان 16 مستشفى تعرضت للقصف منذ بدايه
الاشتباكات واكدت ايضا تعرض مستشفى
البراحه في الخرطوم بحري يوم امس
للقصف انا اشكرك على وجودك معي عبر الهاتف
من الخرطوم رئيس تحرير صحيفه الجريده اشرف
عبد العزيز شكرا جزيلا لك
حضر رئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد
الله حمدوق من ان نزاع في السودان قد
يتفاقن الى احدى اسوا الحروب الاهليه في
العالم في حال لم يتم وضع حد له واعتبر ان
ذلك سيشكل كابوسا للعالم وستكون له
تداعيات كبيره راى حمدوك ان نزاع الحالي
عباره عن حرب لا معنى لها مؤكدا الا احد
سيخرج منها منتصرا
في الاثناء قال المتحدث الرسمي لقوى
الحريه والتغيير العربيه قال ان القوه
السياسيه تتواصل مع اطراف دوليه واطراف
عسكريه في الداخل للتفاوض والوصول الى حل
للازمه لانه نحن على تواصل برضه مع مع
اطراف دوليه ومع بعض الاطراف من العسكريين
في الداخل
للنقاش معهم حول يعني ما يمكن ان يتم من
تفاوض لانهاء هذه الازمه بالتالي هم ابدو
الموافقه وهذا معلوم بالتالي نعتقد انه
الام ما يدور لطالما انه الطرفين وافقوا
على الحوار يبقى استمرار المعارك واضح انه
هو لتحسين الموقف على الارض
توعد عدد من انصار نظام الرئيس المازول
عمر البشير بنشر الفوضى في السودان من اجل
قطع الطريق امام اي اتفاق تتاسس بموجبه
حكومه مدنيه والتي ستقطع الطريق امام
عودتهم للحكم مجددا قيادات اخوانيه في
نظام البشير شنت حمله تحريض واسعه لاشعال
الحرب وعدم تحقيق انتقال نحو حكومه مدنيه
على ركام الحرب الجاريه في السودان انصار
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير يبحثون عن موطئ
قدم فالحرب فرصتهم الوحيده وستحدد مصيرهم
انصار البشير وحزب المؤتمر الوطني
الاخواني توعدوا بنشر الفوضى في البلاد
قطعا للطريق امام اي اتفاق تتاسس بموجبه
حكومه مدنيه فالحكومه المدنيه الديمقراطيه
تعني بالاساس عدم عودتهم للحكم مجددا
بعدما قادوا البلاد لمده 30 عاما بقبضه من
حديد
هؤلاء شنوا حمله تحريض واسعه لاشعال الحرب
وما ان اشتعلت حتى ظلوا يطالبون
باستمرارها بل وصل الامر باحد خطبائهم لحد
اصدار فتوى بقتل المدنيين المعارضين
لتواصل الاشتباكات فان بعض الناس لا لا
يكف شره الا بان يقطع دابره وان يقتل لانه
مرض على الخيانه والنفاق خاصه انا اقول
ليس المقاتلين فقط يعني هناك من الاحزاب
العميله من كان ينفخ في نار هذه الحرب
ويهدد بها الحمله استهلها القيادي الحاج
ادم يوسف محرضا انصار حزبه اذ حثهم على
مواجهه القوى المؤيده للحكم المدني
اما انتخابات او مداخلات احسن مداخل
تمشي تقع في تقع في الشارع ما كبير
القيادي في الحركه والوالي السابق الذي
اشتهر بمواقفه المتطرفه انس عمر وصف
الحكومه المدنيه الانتقاليه بالفاشله
كاشفا عن دورهم في اسقاطها ومهددا في
الوقت ذاته باسقاط اي حكومه مدنيه
للمره الثانيه
اما نائب البشير الاسبق ابراهيم محمود فقد
وجه انصار حزبه بالاستعداد للنزول الى
الميدان في حال توقيع الاتفاق السياسي
النهائي نحن نقول الان استعدوا يا اخواني
جاهزين هذا الاتفاق لو اعلم كل الشعب
السوداني لازم يكون في الميدان
انصار حزب المؤتمر الوطني الذي تزعمه
البشير رفعوا شعارا جديدا يقوم على تخوين
كل من ينادي بوقف الحرب حمله الترهيب
والتخوين والتشويه والتخويف هذه تستهدف
قاده القوى المدنيه التي اسقطت نظام
البشير بالثوره الشعبيه في ربيع العام
انصار البشير نشطوا بعيده توقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي اتشن حمله تحريض ضخمه ضد هذا
الاتفاق الذي يقضي بتسليم السلطه للمدنيين
التحليلات والوقائع تشير الى ان جماعه
الاخوان وانصار البشير يعتبرون الحرب
الدائره معركتهم الاخيره يلقون فيها بكل
اسلحتهم الامر الذي يجعل سيناريو الحرب
الوحيد المتاحه امام بقائهم فلا خيار اخر
لهم في مواجهه الرفض الشعبي الواسع
لعودتهم الى الحكم من جديد
ما يحدث في السودان ليس حربا بين جنرالين
هناك اطراف لاعبه دورا في تصعيد المواجهه
وتستفيد من هذه الازمه
انضم الينا من الخرطوم محلل العسكري
الفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين اهلا بك فريق
فتح الرحمن
بدايه باعتقادك ما يحدث الان
ما شاهدناه من احتراق لمؤسسات وطنيه من
بينها البنك المركزي وايضا هذه الانباء عن
استهداف المستشفيات حسب نقابه الاطباء
وايضا الاسواق والمراكز وكل مقدرات الدوله
الى اي مدى تتناغم مع ما اعلنه انصار
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير
وتمثل صبا للزيت على النار المشتعل الان
في السودان
المشاهدين حضرتك انا اقول يعني للاسف معظم
الذين يتحدثون والذين يكتبون التقارير
يزرعوا الى لا يعمق الحقيقه
الامر اصبحت جليا واضحا الذين احتلوا
المستشفيات يقولون احد الاطراف في النزاع
المسلح وهم يعلمون يقينا انهم هم عناصر
التمرد والدعم السريع هذه هي التي احتلت
المستشفيات احتلت مستشفى الساحه مستشفى
الراغي مستشفى مستشفى البراحه مستشفى
الخرطوم يقول لها عناصر الدعم السريع وكل
المقاطع المصوره توضح عناصر الدعم السريع
يليا بزيهم الواضح
داخل كل الهجوم على البنوك سواء كان بنك
السودان او بنك ام درمان الوطني او بنك
الخرطوم كل هذه الهجمات على البنوك تبداء
عناصر الدعم السريع تفتح البنك تنهض ما
تنهب ثم تترك الامر بعد ذلك هكذا يعني
لعامه
للعامه في الشارع من اراد ان يدخل ليدخل
منكسر السجون واخرج المجرمين من السجون هم
عناصر الدعم السريع وسمعنا توباك المتهم
بمقتل العميد بريما صرح قال نحن كنا في
سجن الهدى ودخلت علينا عناصر الدعم السريع
فتحت لنا الزنازين وخرجنا
وسمعنا الذين خرجوا من سجى قالوا فتحت لنا
ناصر الدعم السريع في جلسوبا وخرجنا الذين
اخرج المجرمين من السجون عناصر الدعم
السريع والذي ينفذ كل هذه الاعمال
الدراميه وهم مع ناصر الدعم السريعه
تجول الخطه الخطه اللي هي خطه
المشرق فوضى
والارهاب في الخرطوم وتقريب اكبر قدر ممكن
لذلك هاجموا محطات الكهرباء هذا المياه
يهاجمون المستشفيات
السؤال اين الجيش من كل ما يحدث لماذا
يسمح الجيش
لعناصر قوات الدعم السريع بان تفعل ما
يحلو لها في العاصمه الخرطوم دون حسيب او
رقيب
تقاتل حوالي 80 الف متمرد داخل الخرطوم
ومعزمني ينتشر وسط الاحياء السكنيه ويعمل
بنظام حرب العصابات يسهر في مكان يعني
مثلا التي هاجمت بنك السودان هاجمت بنك
السودان قبل زمن الافطار في رمضان بحوالي
ثلث ساعه
وفي خلال زمن وجز جدا نفذوا نهبوا ما
نهبوا ثم جعلوا النار وسحبوا يعني ما
بيحتفظوا بالموقع اللي بيحتدوا عنه وهذا
وهذا يحيينا الى سؤال اذا استمرت المعركه
على هذا النحو 80 الف شخص
ربما مسلحين على عربات تتنقل في احياء
العاصمه فهذا يعني بان المواجهه لن تنتهي
وستبقى الى ما لا نهايه وهو ما تنبا به
عبد الله حمدوك رئيس الوزراء السابق
بالعكس
تمام في السودان الان 80,000 الذي يحدثك
عنهم الان لم يتبقى منهم الا يمكن اقل من
8000 معظم هذه القوه اما استسلمت لغات
المسلحه واما هاربه قتلت الان القوات
المسلحه التسعه لفرض هيبه الدوله في
الخرطوم بعد بعد الاطمئنان على كل
الولايات كل الولايات الان مستقره تماما
دعنا نتحدث عن المعارك التي حدثت بالامس
والتي الى الان حسب الكثير من الضيوف
الذين يعني خرجوا معنا في قناه العربيه
اكدوا بانه الى الان لم تحسم لاي طرف على
حساب الاخر وهي مناطق على مدى اسابيع شهدت
هذه الاشتباكات المهندسين الصالحه
محيط القياده العامه القصر الرئاسي لماذا
الى الان لم ينجح الجيش في حسم هذه
المعارك
الجيش غير متعدل لحزم هذه المعارك لان هذه
المناطق كما ذكرنا مناطق فيها
تحسدات السكنيه ام ابرياء والدعم السريع
ينتشر ويتخذ منهم ذراع بشريه وبالتالي لا
ترغب في مزيد من الطحين المدنيين تتعامل
مع كل هذه المناطق التي فيها كثافه سكانيه
عاليه بسياسه النفس الطويل
يعني
فريق فتح الرحمن مع ذلك الان نقابه
الاطباء تعلن كل يوم ارتفاع حصيله القتلى
والجرحى والمصابين يعني هذه الحرب يعني
تودي بحياه المدنيين استمرارها ايضا يعني
ارتفاع هذه الارقام وبالتالي الى اي الى
اي مدى هذه الفكره باستمرار الحرب ستؤدي
الى مزيد من القتلى اليس الاحرار التزام
الطرفين
بالهدنه التي ربما تجنب المدنيين المزيد
من الخسائر
والله انا اعتقد انه لغات المسلحه هي
دائما تلتزم بالهدنه تلتزم بالجنه لتحسين
الوضع الانساني والذي بدا يتحسن كثيرا
ولتحت المجال للاجانب والفساد الدبلوماسيه
لكي تغادر لمكان في من يرى بالمغادره ولكن
عناصر الدعوه الشريعه هي الان اصبحت تنصب
المدافع الثقيله السكنيه وتقصد بها
الاحياء السكنيه هذا ما ما نشاهده وما
يحدث الان الان الغاز المس على مساحات
واسعه وبدات تنشر عناصر الشرطه في المناطق
التي تعتمد عليها حتى يستتب الامن
وتتفادى العمل الاجرامي الذي يمكن ان يقوم
به المجرمين الذين خرجوا من السجون الان
الجاري عمليه تطهير المناطق الطرفيه ولكن
المناطق التي يتحشت فيها الابرياء القوات
المسلحه حريصه التي تتعامل مثل ما شاهدنا
ذلك في كثير من الدول عندما يكون هنالك
تمرد ويتخذ دروع بشريه تنسف المنطقه
بالكامل
فريق فتح الرحمن
لن يعني ذلك ان هنالك
ايمكن ان يضبط
ون لكم هذا الكلام اكثر من مره ان اردتم
ان تاخذوا البيانات الصحيحه عن المستشفيات
وعن الضحايا وعن الجثث في الشوارع خذوها
من الناطق الرسمي ولايه الصحه بوزاره
الصحه بولايه هذه الجهه الرسميه التي لكن
غابه الاطباء وحتى الذين تحدثوا بمناسبه
الصحه العالميه
الصادره عن نقابه الاطباء
يشكك فيها بالتاكيد لا مصداقيه لهم سؤال
اخير فريق فتح الرحمن
سمعنا لكل التصريحات التي النظام البيت هم
يتحدثوا عن مدافعه الحكومه التي ستاتي من
الاتفاقسيا بالتظاهر بالاضرابات
المدنيه ولكن اطلاقا تحدث احد
وصلت فكره وصلت فكره دعني فقط اسالك سؤال
يعني في تخصصك
سمعناها من ياسر عرمان من وصلت فكره فقط
اسمح لي ان اسالك سؤال يعني فيما يتعلق
بتبادل اتهامات بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش بخرق الهدنه يعني الجيش يقول بانه
قوه الدعم السريع خلقت الهدنه وفي نفس
البيان يقول قمنا بشن هجوم وطائرات تحلق
في سماء العاصمه وايضا قوات الدعم تقتتهم
الجيش بانه خرق الهدنه وتعلن انها احتلت
مناطق وسيطرت على مناطق اخرى كيف يعني
يمكن فهم هذا الامر الطرفان يعلنان تحقيق
انجازات على الارض وبنفس الوقت يتهمان
الطرف الاخر بخرق الهدنه
طيب الغوات المسلحه ظلت تلتزم بالهدنه
ولكن عناصر الدعم السريعه على سبيل المثال
هذه الهدنه اللي نحن فيها الان دي
دعم هي التي هاجمت قوات الدفاع الجوي في
منطقه جبلولي وهي داخل معسكره فكيف تكون
انت ملتزم بالهنا وتاتي الي في معسكر
وتهاجمني ثم بعد ذلك تطلب مني ان لا ارد
عليك يجب ان ارد عليك وان استخدم الطيران
حتى في المناطق المكشوفه لك
ي يرد
استخدامك للقوه لياتي في اطار انك تدافع
عن نفسك وكل ما هم يهجمون منطقه يتم
التعامل معهم بالطريقه التي تتناسب مع
المنطقه الموجودين فيها بالاسلحه التي
تناسب المنطقه الموجودين فيها
كل الهدى السابقه لحتى الان نحن نعتمد انه
القوات المسلحه مكبله مكبله بهذه الهدن
التي تفرض نحن نعمل عندما تنتهي الهدنه
هذه اليوم الا تكون هنالك هدنه جديده
اتركوا المجال للغات المسلحه
واللغات المسلحه ايضا تتحلى الفرصه لكي
تعمل شكرا جزيلا لك نر
ى شكرا فريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين المحل
العسكري كنت معنا عبر الهاتف من الخرطوم
في متابعه للاوضاع الطبيه اكد المسؤول
الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر السوداني للعربيه
ان العمل داخل المستشفيات يجري بامكانيات
محدوده جدا وان هناك حاجه ماسه لوصول
المساعدات من الخارج لتجاوز الاوضاع التي
باتت مترتديه
الوضع على عادات من بعض الجهات حتى
المنظمات
بما موجود عندها من مخزون ثابت ومعظم
المنظمات بما فيها حتى الهلال الاحمر
السوداني وغيرها كل المنظمات المعنيه
بمساعده لمساعدات الانسانيه وبتعمل في
القطاع الصحي في وضع طبيعي كجانب جوانب
العمل الانساني مخزون طبيعي لكن مخزون
الحالات العاديه للحالات الطارئه في الوضع
العاليه
فدلوقتي بتدبر اضافه الى
مساهمات
الاطباء لتشكيلاتهم المختلفه بهيئات
بنقابات
بتنظيمهم الحالي لمجابهه الواقع الناس
بتتبرع من ومن الخاص وكذا لكن عشان نبدا
نجابها الموجوده دي لازم تجي مساعدات من
الخارج
[موسيقى]
حاليا الادويه
اللي خلصت عندنا تماما او على وشك يا
ادويه الضغط
[موسيقى]
الاحداث الدوحه مش بنسلين
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن ولدها تفتش وما خلوه
اي حته فتش عشان تقول اي
[موسيقى]
لو مع استمرار اشتباكات يزداد الضغط على
القطاع الصحي في السودان حتى اصبح الحديث
عن انهيار النظام الصحي امرا غير مستمر
من سيء الى اسوا انهيار النظام الصحي في
السودان بات وشيكا في كل يوم يزداد عدد
المرافق الصحيه التي تخرج عن الخدمه
الواحده تلو الاخرى جراء القصف او النقص
المعدات والمستلزمات الطبيه او بسبب غياب
الكوادر الطبيه وضع اذا استمر وبنفس
الوتيره سيهدد وقريبا بالاغلاق التام
لكافه المرافق الصحيه الرسميه في ظل تواصل
العمليات العسكريه وفقا لنقابه الاطباء
السودانيه لكن الذي اريد ان اؤكده ان
هنالك ليس هنالك ضمانات للممرات الامنه
فهناك ما يحدث في الجنينين انما هي مبدا
انسانيه مجزره بشريه مخالف لكل
القوانين الدوليه غياب الممره كذلك خلال
الهدنه التي يتم خرقها في كل مره سبب
رئيسي لعزل هذه المرافق الحيويه وجعلها
مكانا خطيرا لا يمكن الوصول اليه مع
استباحه واستهداف كل من طرفي نزاعلها لا
يقتصر انهيار النظام الصحي فقط على مناطق
الاشتباكات بالخرطوم بل يمتدوا الى جميع
الاقاليم التي تاثرت بانقطاع الامداد
الدوائي ونزوح الاطباء خارج البلاد
الجثث عددها كبيره جدا واحد اثنين اتساعا
الجغرافيه بتاعه ولايه الخرطوم يعني ان
احنا لو عايزين نغطي ولايه الخرطوم كلها
بمحليات السبعه هي هي حاجه ضخمه جدا
ارتفاع اعداد المصابين تسبب ايضا بالضغط
على القطاع الصحي واستنزاف الموارد
الموجوده
حيث شهدت مدينه كسلا الواقعه في اقصى
الشرق والتي تبعد قرابه 600 كيلومتر عن
الخرطوم نقصا حادا في اسطوانات الاكسجين
فضلا عن انعدام اكياس الدم بانحاء الولايه
كالرمحناوي العربيه
اذا نتابع مشاهدينا هذه الصور المباشره
التي تاتينا من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
هذه الصور تظهر ربما اثار الاشتباكات التي
حدثت صباح اليوم
وخرق الهدنه الذي اتهم الجيش السوداني
قوات الدعم السريع بتنفيذها وايضا قوات
الدعم اتهمت الجيش بخرق هذه الهدنه طبعا
اكد الجيش استمرار القصف العشوائي من قبل
قوات الدعم السريع
وعمليات نهب ممتلكات وقال بانه ايضا قوات
الدعم حولت مستشفى شرق النيل الى ثقنه
عسكريه ومركز قياده لعملياتها في المقابل
قوه الدعم السريع كانت اتهمت ايضا الجيش
بمهاجمه مواقع تمركزها في عدد من مناطق
الخرطوم وبالتالي هذه الهدنه كسابقتها
تخللتها الكثير من الخروقات والمواجهات
رغم ان ساعات الليل شهدت هد وء نسبيا لكن
مع ساعات الصباح عادت الامور لتتجدد من
جديد
واعاده المواجهات بين الجانبين لتحتدم
والصوره تتحدث عن نفسها
نعود الى الاوضاع الصحيه تفاقمها انعكسا
على قطع الدواء وسط مخاوف من كارثه كبيره
في توفير الدواء في العاصمه الخرطوم مع
استمرار الاشتباكات
صيدليات مغلقه ورفوف ادويه شبه فارغه هذه
حصيله نحو اسبوعين من الاشتباكات يضاف لها
عمليات نهب واسعه طالت صيدليات ومخازن
ادويه في العاصمه السودانيه هنا في مدينه
ام درمان يستمر اغلاق عدد كبير من
الصيدليات منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات في ظل
تحذيرات من تفاقم الازمه الصحيه على مستوى
البلاد علينا الادويه
الخلصه عندنا تماما او على وشك يا ادويه
الضغط وادويه السكري
والادويه اللي بتشتغل على الجهاز العصبي
او الادويه التاثير العصبي
خصوصا مرضى الصرع
دي الناس طبعا اساسا عندهم مشكله في الحي
الادويه دي اساسا ما متوفره في الظروف
العاديه فيها شح والان المشكله بقت اكبر
تهدد الازمه الحاليه صحه الكبار والصغار
على حد سواء فاسعار الادويه بارتفاع مستمر
فيما اصنافها المتوفره بانخفاض
مقلقز الاحداث الدوحه
انسانين
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن ولدها تفتشوا ما خلوه
اي حته فتش عشان القليب
خلينا صيدليه ما لقينا ما خلينا حتى ما
لقينا وحتى عربيه يتحركوا بها عشان يجيبوا
لي الدواء ما في بنزين ما في هناك طريقه
نمرق من البلد عشان نمشي نفتش الدواء
نجيبه اما بالنسبه للمستشفيات فلا يزال
القليل منها الذي يعمل في الخرطوم يعاني
نقصا حادا في الادويه والمستلزمات
العلاجيه الاخرى خاصه المتعلقه
بالجرحى والمحاليل الوريديه ما يفاقم من
معاناه المرضى مع استمرار توقف الامداد
الدوائي الحكومي نور الحصني العربيه
[موسيقى]
وعلى وقع استمرار الاشتباكات وغياب اي
بوادر حل قريب وصف برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه الوضع الانساني في السودان
بالكارثي
شوارع الخرطوم شبه خاليه لا امن ولا امان
اما اسواقها يكبل الكساد ايدي التجار فيها
فالمعروض قليل والطلب شبه معدوم
اقتصاد السودان صعد على سكه خسائر لا يمكن
التصور ابعادها وبات شبح المجاعه يهدد كل
من تقطعت بهم سبل الخروج منه برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي وصف الوضع الانساني في
البلاد بالكارثي مؤكدا انه يجب ان يتوقف
القتال اولا لتمكين ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه بامان
وضع انساني يزداد كل يوم سوءا وتحيط به
مخاوف من ارتفاع جنني في اسعار المواد
الغذائيه والوقود معنى فادي الاموال
والامدادات الاساسيه وتعطل الانظمه
المصرفيه
حالهم بات غايه في السوق والتردي واصعب
مهامهم تامين قوتهم اليومي وحاجاتهم
الغذائيه حيث شهدت اسعار السلع
الاستهلاكيه الضروريه في العاصمه الخرطوم
ارتفاعا كبيرا ومفاجئا مع اعتبره
السودانيون غير مبرر في حين عزاه البعض
الى استغلال التجار لظروف المواطنين
الصعبه
اندلاع الحرب جدد المخاوف من انزلاق
الاقتصاد السوداني نحو الانهيار الشامل
فمع دخول الحرب الاسبوع الثالث واستمرار
عمليات الاجلاء سترتفع احتمالات اصابه
النشاط الاقتصادي بالشلل وستنجر البلاد
نحو مصير مظلم واكبر خطرا
اياد حمود العربيه
وعلى خلفيات المواجهات المسلحه مستمره بدا
الموظفون في ولايه الخرطوم بعطله رسميه
حتى اشعار اخر وذلك بسبب الظروف الامنيه
التي تعيش البلاد ولا تشمل العطله غرف
اداره الازمه والمرافق الخدميه الحيويه
في سياق متصل الاعلانات ولايتها القضارف
ونهر النيل في السودان حاله الطوارئ
لمواجهه تداعيات الاشتباكات الجاريه حاليا
في البلاد حيث امر والقضارف باعلان حاله
الطوارئ لمده شهر مؤكدا ان من يخالف
الاوامر يعرض نفسه للغرامه او السجن هذا
واعلن والي نهر النيل ايضا حاله الطوارئ
بالولايه ووجه الجهات المختصه بتنفيذ
الامر وفق وسائل الاعلام محليه
اما في ولايه غرب دارفور فقد اعلنت نقابه
الاطباء حصر 94 وفجر الاشتباكات في مدينه
الجنينه قبل ذلك اعلن الجيش السوداني في
بيان ان لجنه امن الولايه نجحت بالحد من
التوتر القبلي وان شرطه الاحتياطي تفتح
تدريجيا مناطق في جنوب الخرطوم الجيش
السوداني اشاره في بيانه الى ان الموقف
العملياتي مستقر في جميع المناطق العسكريه
بالبلاد مؤكدا استمرار بعض الدول باجلاء
رعاياها من الخرطوم وبورتسودان
اظهر مقطع فيديو انتشر على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي لحظه فرار طلاب في جامعه
الخرطوم من صوت اطلاق النار عند احد
المداخل نتابع
[تصفيق]
وفي متابعه لجهود السعوديه في عمليات
الاجلاء من السودان افاد مراسل العربيه
بان طائره السعوديه اجلت 82 شخصا بينهم
خمسه واربعون سعوديا من بورتسودان الى
ميناء جده
[موسيقى]
وانضم الينا من قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه في جده مراسل العربيه هنصفيان اهلا
بك هاني اذا يستمر هذا الجهد السعودي
باجلاء السودانيين وايضا باقي الجاليات من
بورت سودان الى جده ضعنا في اخر التفاصيل
الطائره السعوديه التي وصلت واعداد من كان
على متنها واذا كان هناك طائرات اخرى
قادمه
نعم اذا جسر جوي متواصل وما زال مستمرا
هنا في قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
طائرات عسكريه تابعه للقوات الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه وطائرات اخرى عسكريه
اجنبيه هناك بعض الاحصائيات الخاصه
بالعربيه والتي استطعناها الحصول عليها
وهي ان من خلال هذه القاعده نفذت او
استقبلت اكثر من 47 رحله جويه خلال
نقلت وكذلك او اجمالي ما تم نقله وكذلك
مغادرتهم من الرعايه من جنسيات مختلفه
تجاوزوا
4200 شخص لدينا 28 رحله كانت قادمه من
بورتسودان الى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه هنا في جده كانت القوات الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه تقود هذه المه نقلت من
خلال هذه الرحلات اكثر من
2123 راكب بينما كانت هناك تسعه عشره رحله
جويه مغادره نقلت
2144 راكب طبعا هذه الرحلات كانت بعضها
لطائرات عسكريه سواء تابعه للقوات الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه او كذلك طائرات عسكريه
اجنبيه او كذلك عبر الطيران التجاري طبعا
ما زلنا في قاعده الملك فقط اسمح لي على
المقاطعه هاني يعني حسب الارقام اللي
تحدثت عنها 28 رحله نقلت
223 شخص وايضا تسعه عشره رحله نقلت 2144
يعني نتحدث بالمجمل ان جل هؤلاء هم من
جنسيات ليست سعوديه وان يعني عدد قليل
منهم سعوديون
صحيح صحيح نتحدث تحديدا عن رحلات كانت
قادمه من بورت سودان الى قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه عدد الرحلات 28 رحله نقلت
2123 راكب معظمهم من جنسيات ورعاية من
جاليات متعدده اعداد السعوديين لم
يتجاوزوا
الخمسه وثمانين شخصا في مجمل هذه الرحلات
الجويه فقط نحن نتحدث عن رحلات الجويه اما
ايضا عن الرحلات المغادره فقد كانت من هذه
القاعده الى الدول هذه الرعايه كانت تسعه
عشر رحله وكانت اعداد او اعداد الركاب
كانوا
2144 اذا نتحدث عن اجمال لعدد الرحلات
المغادره والقادمه 47 رحله كانت مغادره
وقادمه ولكن هذه هذه هذا العدد كان خلال
الاسبوع منذ بدء عمليه الاجلاء التي تمت
في الرابع والعشرين من هذا الشهر وتحديدا
يوم الاثنين عمليات الاجلاء وعمليات الجسر
الجوي ما زال مستمرا وبينما نحن نتحدث عن
الجسر الجوي هنا في قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه وهو القاعده الوحيده التي تستقبل
هؤلاء الرعايه بسبب ايضا ان هذا هذه
القاعده مخصصه للطائرات العسكريه سواء
التابعه للقوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه
او كذلك الطائرات العسكريه الاخرى هناك
عبر الموانع المخصصه من قبل السعوديه
وتحديدا عبر ميناء جده الاسلامي وكذلك
قاعده الملك فيصل الحربيه فانه ما زال
مستمرا استقبال عدد السفن سواء تجاريه او
كذلك العسكريه ومن خلال البيانات الرسميه
التي ايضا اصدرتها السعوديه من خلال عدد
الرعايه والذين يتجاوزوا او لامسوا الخمسه
الاف راكب وشخص من جنسيات مختلفه وبلغوا
اعداد الجنسيات حتى الان اكثر من 90 جنسيه
تفضل السؤال الاخير فيما يتعلق بجهود
اجلاء السعوديين
المعلومات حول طريقه التواصل والتنسيق لكي
يتلاقوا خدمات من البعثات الدبلوماسيه
السعوديه في السودان لتنسيق عودتهم كيف
تتم
طبعا هناك استعدادات وتجهيزات سواء في
داخل السودان هناك كانت الرسائل وايضا لدى
السفاره السعوديه بيانات خاصه باعداد
السعوديين الموجودين لديهم وايضا عند وصول
هؤلاء السعوديين او كذلك الرعايه من
جنسيات مختلفه التي اوضحت ايضا اوصبح
معروفا لدى الرايه هناك في السودان ان
منطقه بورت سودان واي تحديدا عند نادي
الموانئ هي منطقه لتجمع ويتواجد فيها او
تتواجد فيها السفاره السعوديه واعضاء
ومنسوبي السفاره السعوديه فيتم انهاء
اجراءاتهم سواء باجلائهم عبر الطائرات
العسكريه او كذلك
الاسطول البحري وعند وصولهم يتم ايضا
استقبالهم من خلال تاكد اولا من صحتهم عبر
العياده المخصصه هنا في القوات الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه وبعد ذلك منحهم تاشيرات
طارئه وانهاء اجراءاتهم وهذه المده التي
يتم انها فيها اجراءاتهم التي تتجاوز
الثلاثين الثانيه لانها تعمل بتقنيات
عاليه وبعد ذلك كان نقلهم عبر حافلات
مخصصه لمقر اقامتهم تفضل شكرا العربيه كنت
معنا مباشره من قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه في جده
اما بالنسبه للجراء الشماليه مصر فاتستمر
عمليات نزوح السودانيين بالاشتباكات الى
الحدود الفاصله بين البلدين وبينما تقلصت
اعداد القادمين الى معبر
زادت نسبه الوافدين عبر منفذ قسطل ومنه
تمر الحافلات الواصله عبر عباره نيفيا نحو
مدينه ابو سمبل
[موسيقى]
هكذا تبدو بوابه الخروج من معبر ارجين
تقلص كبير في اعداد القادمين من السودان
وتقلص ايضا في اعداد الحافلات التي
تنتظرهم منذ اكثر من اسبوعين
[موسيقى]
حولهم بقى على المعبر الثاني اللي هو
النهري ده بس وحولوا الاتوبيسات وحولوا
الناس كلها على هناك النهارده الحركه
خفيفه قد تكون الحركه مقص طبعا من الجانب
الاشتباكات بس احنا ما نعرفش اي حاجه ايه
اللي حاصل في الجانب السوداني
[موسيقى]
اصحابه سيارات نقل البضائع الكبيره
سينجحون اخيرا في المرور من معبر ارجين
والدخول الى الاراضي السودانيه بعد توقف
دام اكثر من اسبوعين
[موسيقى]
نحن الان داخل احد الحافلات التي خرجت
اخيرا من معبر ارجين من يستقلون هذه
الحافله يشعرون بالارهاق وتحدثوا معنا على
معلومه من خلال هذه الرحله الطويله ده لكل
الناس تتجه لحالفه
فاحنا كنا اخر بس جاي على ارجينا
[موسيقى]
في قريب 30 باص والمعبر زحمه شديد لكن
احنا شنو
خشينا بس عملنا الاجراءات ولقينا خلينا
على بعض مصريه جابتنا جابتنا
[موسيقى]
وسواء كان القادمون ياتون من خلال البري
او ميميائي ابو سمبل النيلي فان الرحله
تكتمل اخيرا بالوصول الى الحدود المصريه
احمد عثمان
لقناتي العربيه والحدث من ميناء ابو سمبل
النيلي
[موسيقى]
قال متحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قوات موسكو قصفت موقع القياده والمراقبه
للطائرات العسكريه الاوكرانيه قربه منطقه
خيرسون والحقت وحدات المدفعيه اضرارا
بنيرانها بموقع القياده والمراقبه ومركز
التحكم للطائرات بدون طيار التابعه للواء
124 من قوات الدفاع الاقليميه التابعه
لكيف مضيفا ان قوات موسكو دمرت مستودع
تخزين الذخيره والمعدات قرب المدينه
الساحليه جنوب البلاد موضحا ان القصف
الروسي اسفر عن مقتل 30 شخصا من صفوف
القوات الاوكرانيه وتدمير اكثر من عشر
مركبات قتاليه مصفحه
من جانبه تعهد رئيس الاوكرانيه بمحاسبه
روسيا عقب سقوط عشرات القتلى والجراحه
جراء قصفها لمدينه اومان الاوكرانيه
وفي اخر تطورات الاوضاع بمدينه باخمه تدور
المعارك منذ اشهر هناك وقال متحدث باسم
القوات الاوكرانيه ان بلاده لا تزال تسيطر
على طريق امداد هام مؤذن الى المدينه
مؤكدا لوسائل الاعلام محليه ان الوضع في
باخموت لا يزال صعبا بسبب محاولات القوات
الروسيه السيطره على طريق الحياه المؤديه
للمدينه الى ان قوتي بلاده لن تسمح للروس
بقطع الخدمات اللوجستيه للجيش الاوكراني
افادت وكاله بلومبرج بان الدول الاوروبيه
باتت تضع قيودا جديده على الصادرات
والاستثمارات الصينيه بسبب استيائها من
علاقات بكين الوثيقه مع رئيس بوتين مشيره
الى ان دولا مثل المانيا وايطاليا تدوسان
وضع الضوابط التي اعتمدتها الولايات
المتحده على التصدير والاستثمار الاستهداف
الصين ووفقا للوكاله فان واشنطن والاتحاد
الاوروبي يعملان على التطوير ادوات جديده
لابطاء تقدم الصين في عده مجالات تشمل
اشباه الموصلات والدفاع مضيفه انهما
يتناقشان وضع ضوابط على التصدير وتجديد
الرقابه على الاستثمارات وزياده التعاون
في مجال المواد الحيويه
قبل ايام من معاوده الكنيست عمله بعد عطله
تجددت الاحتجاجات في اسرائيل ضد مشروع
اصلاح النظام القضائي الذي اقترحته
الحكومه برئاسه بنيامين نتنياهو وتجمع نحو
150 الى 200 الف شخص وفق تقدير وسائل
اعلام محليه
اعلنا رجل الاعمال الملياردير لهم ماسك عن
خطه لمنصه تويتر تسمحليل وسائل الاعلاميه
بتقاضي بدل من المستخدمين على اساس قراءه
كل مقاله على حده وبنقره واحده وقال ماسك
ان الخطه ستمكن المستخدمين الذين لم
يشتركوا شهريا للدفع بدل اعلى مقابل قراءه
كل مقاله بشكل عابر وان الامر سيشكل مكسب
رئيسيا للمؤسسات الاعلاميه والجمهور
نهايه هذه الساعه الاخباريه التي خصصنا
معظمها لتغطيه اخبار السودان هذه الاخبار
المستمره لكن على راس ساعه مع الزميل نايف
الاحمري تفضلوا بالبقاء معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات